now I want to I want to tell you what
started this thought I had a tweet
earlier this week talking about how no
at 35 you cannot compete with 22y olds
and the reason I had that thought was I
looked at the most beautiful 35-year-old
women that I know and I thought to
myself okay their their skin still sags
they still got light wrinkles or they
got a Botox forehead either or you know
whatever pick your poison um they have
fake whitened teeth like they they've
they've or maybe a fake BBL whatever
money they've put into staying
attractive I I don't care I'm not even
hating on it but my point is they spend
all of this money fake boobs the gym
whatever only to not be able to compete
with a 22-year-old